[ __ ] about food you don't know anything
about food if you want for that [ __ ]
dude what do you have what do I want to
be a boring [ __ ] that's like money
got to go to this restaurant dude [ __ ]
those kinds of guys you know what [ __ ]
the kinds of guys how about the guys
when you're like when you're like on the
road and they're like hey you got to go
to this place and you're like I'll do my
show
Thanks oh let me go out of my way to a
[ __ ] but it's good food some [ __ ]
smoke out see ya hey dude I live in Los
Angeles I can get all the good food dude
I'm gonna be in all yo I'm in Cleveland
crisis smokehouse in Columbus I help you
out
put your face under my balls bro let me
rub my taint on your [ __ ] eyes come on
- huh nah dude don't be nice to me bro
be regular all right well what if I go
almost figured all that out to lunch
today bro hey I give a [ __ ] Brahman a
faint sitting down have you ever done
that what have you what did you do last
night that you would face you look like
Sean Penn at birth
do you see Jeb in the night show every
night he it's like a stack of packing no
dude that's off this off being this
ballast see dude I [ __ ] eat real good
like what chocolate chip pancakes no man
ie no [ __ ] protein ding ding yeah
are you protein ping ping and I [ __ ]
you know I make sure I eat the leafy
greens and your neck is jutting your
heads jutting it forward your isn't in
line with your shoulder you look tired
yeah I'm tired as [ __ ] why man I'm so
tired it's really new preface I gotta
eat after this hey what kind of [ __ ]
cool hot spot do you want to go dude how
about Brian when he [ __ ] post in the
Instagram video of him and his friends
in a dark I'm alone and I go like this
god [ __ ] they got mad I know I
did it for the frizzy [ __ ] look at your
face Bryant in your eyes
I got hey listen look Oh guys this thing
think maybe I'll get my give me I'll get
my eyes just tucked up hi good time
though
yeah you could live out there huh I sure
could live out there I sure could now
not in the summer I don't know if you
know about the summer but it's about a
thousand degrees either me man well I
can't do Vegas in the summer miserable
this isn't too bad but I want you to
take Vegas heat and then I want a dress
I want you to get I want you to add
Vegas necessary if a normal percent well
I've been there been Houston the summer
did snap and use the summer yeah it's
hot
locusts I'm not too worried though
because mom indoors you see you are
indoors but very rarely hanging that
heat is like a big old wet blanket on
you now I do well in in wet heat meters
like my skin doesn't my hair gets curly
might break out my ass gets super sweaty
but um yeah I could live in Texas
there's one place that you live outside
California be Texas I agree with you
100% like me more I'll reach in there I
like the people of Texas I Reno why I
like it it's so vast and wide I don't
have to see people here's the other
reason I like it I could have tigers and
lions I think there are more lions and
tigers in Texas then I'll take a look
place in the world this is cool though
and there's no state tax
now listen man it's America America
awesome has that like Austin has also
losing a little bit well yeah that's
true but all in the face where you'll
see a hipster with a [ __ ] nose ring
but he's also packing a piece yeah it's
like oh we're liberal but we believe in
God she's well yeah don't liberal but
we're still yes but this sell taxes
still my property sees step over um I
may have tattoos on my neck and and I'm
wearing Birkenstocks but I'll fully feel
alleged you chose a cap city are the
best the best buy that outfit there I
did buy this shirt there i I've said you
know that the shirt you know mad right
nice I was like maybe I'll just get a
little crazy to get it of course stag my
bag provisions tagged out here I know
who's stags on by the way any so I go
there and I go I want to go here because
this is a store it's an individual store
the guy goes I buy a bunch of stuff he
goes he recognizes and eager bro then
they're avid bro I'm celebrity and he
goes from celebrity and he goes do you
go the one on a bikini I was like ow
[ __ ] I forgot about that you know he's
so hip he's got a rope now do you
approve of the Rope for a belt I do a
Chris yeah what kind of jeans are those
bro caller jeans our guys are guys yep
we have the same coat on last night you
know how much it cost my my I don't know
I don't know you know why just like my
social studies time looking man hey you
[ __ ] what is that what what is that
yeah dude what the [ __ ] bro what are you
doing man what are you doing taking why
you dressed so [ __ ] regular cuz I'm a
[ __ ] regular man no it's not rust
rating in that sense I'm not some
Wallflower alright I'm not some
decorating for these [ __ ] sunglasses
on dude take them off your bird take
them off I won't I won't hey happy bird
take them off right now don't call me
happy you're a happy bird take off right
now Harry dude what were you guys
talking about before I even got here
probably some [ __ ] like some matter Oh
doesn't matter it doesn't matter cuz the
show [ __ ] everything to do as much
with macho guys somebody's talking about
you being strong they said these tough
hiking fight I go what do you mean Kenny
what kind of question is that they used
UFC heavyweight he goes yeah I mean who
the [ __ ] was it he goes um he said who
was he goes how it no he goes um so so
if he kicked your ass right away I got
my what yeah I go he would he could [ __ ]
you dude you know that right you're
grown man Brendan could if he wanted he
could [ __ ] yeah dude I tell you it
wasn't just beat you up you know talk to
Todd filmin to do a lot of boxing which
was playing like he does jiu-jitsu and
although he's the best and we're going
to lunch I you can tell when someone's
joking like you and I joke around time
he was dead so she goes dude I'm just
I'm really curious about this he goes if
I like grabbed you like say you're just
walking to lunch I grabbed
you could I take you down like how fast
could you because you think I could take
you down if I just like surprise you
with seeing a leg and you don't even
tell its own serious I turn 11 you
serious doggies you know it there's
nothing you could do man there's nothing
so let him try let's do a quick song and
we'll all sing a song I'll start and you
add it you add to it and you add to it
ready editor okay can I get a beat done
can you give me a sort of bad let's just
kind of do something real nice let's
shut the lights down on our lives
sometimes you gotta take a break you
gotta decide that rat race is just too
long a chain cut the lights let's go
nuts to butts I'm in the middle it's
gonna feel so good I don't know if
that's a good idea maybe we should just
live our lives the way we've been living
them and not going having sex with the
lights out and never ever listen to
Brian that's not true because if we are
gonna shut the lights out and go nuts to
butts no let's make sure we wrap it up
and now look each other in the eyes
let's run a train on us in the dark
busting nuts in the bus in the trunk and
respective houses and with each other
what did you say what are you saying
busting nuts at our own respective
houses not near each other I'll do mine
in Beverly Hills and you do yours in
wherever you live
you're like an arrogant I'm not but I
don't know where you live what your
situation is it could be in an apartment
or it could be why don't really know me
it may ask about it because I don't want
to bring up the hard times who knows
what's going on with your situation I
don't know what the show knows I'm not
sure what you're talking about but be
quiet anyway yeah yeah
this song was all made up and it's not
ring yeah what do you do when hollywood
finds out you can't fight oh you you're
not gonna work in this a [ __ ] did you
just write on everyone he can fight you
come on Brom trial and this note and and
you got you got bling on your [ __ ] on
your chest they talk about my bag
diamonds yeah dude don't do that please
ah please don't go please help hey I
just got one question yeah I do like it
dude could never get through right dude
I have a question for you
I have a question will you release this
tension when you see my back I pull
myself up like a champ 30 times fast
while talking to you why wouldn't I give
that to you as it's a gift it's a gift
it's a gift